[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition du 7 8 journal de tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de ce mercredi 4
septembre un grenelle et des annonces le
gouvernement a lancé hier pour trois
mois son événement de lutte contre les
violences conjugales alors que le
chiffre de 100 féminicide a été dépassé
depuis le début de l'année en plateau la
réaction de frédéric marty directrice de
l'association roumaine salle face à rj à
saint germain en laye c'est une première
en ile-de-france un radar un peu
particulier a été installé en juillet au
pied de la route des dix sept tournant
méduse c'est son nom doit mettre fin aux
nuisances sonores des motos qui se
croisent par centaines sur cet axe
explications
et puis nouvelle reconnaissance pour le
signer 7 à elancourt après jeune public
patrimoine et répertoires le lieu est
désormais labellisé recherches et
découvertes distinction reçue pendant
l'été à suivre également tout à l'heure
la présentation du 16e motors en sol
l'événement à des passionnés de voitures
et motos anciennes revient ce week end
c'est à granby
ce chiffre pour commencer sans plus de
100 femmes 100 une précisément à l'heure
où je vous parle sont mortes sous les
coups de leur conjoint ou ex conjoint
depuis le début de l'année c'est pour
prendre des engagements concrets contre
les violences conjugales que le
gouvernement a lancé hier un grenelle
dédié lancement d'une campagne notamment
autour du numéro d'écouté anonyme et
gratuit destiné aux femmes victimes de
violence le 39 19
et aussi d'ores et déjà des annonces que
l'on va a commenté avec vous frédéric
martz bon soir vous êtes la directrice
et cofondatrice de l'association women
safe qui prend en charge des femmes
victimes de violences et aussi leurs
enfants saint germain en laye le centre
est situé à saint germain en laye alors
avant de parler avec vous des mesures
déjà une vision globale sur cette
démarche du gouvernement est ce que le
problème des violences faites aux femmes
avec ce grenelle est pris à sa juste
mesure
selon vous je pense que ce bordel il a
été lancée surtout suite à leur
mouvement des femmes des familles en
fait de victimes qui ont fait
effectivement qui ont manifesté place de
la république et c'est à l'issue
effectivement de cette manifestation que
ces familles on va dire peut-être
engendré ce grenelle qui s'est annoncée
comme une fort espoir pour les familles
et pour les victimes actuellement suivie
dans les associations
le seul problème c'est qu'entre le
moment le moment de l' annonce il ya eu
quand même pas mal de femmes mortes sous
les coups donc on est un peu inquiet de
ce grenelle qui doit avancer peut-être
beaucoup plus vite que prévu et vos
attentes autour justement du grenelle
est-ce que c'est davantage
d'associations la vôtre n'était pas par
exemple associé hier au lancement du
grenelle davantage d'associations de
terrain soit soit associée à ce à ce
temps moi ce que j'ai retenu de ce
grenelle c'est prévention des violences
conjugales
la prise en charge des victimes et
finalement la sanction
contre les auteurs notre association n'a
pas été alors qu'on est là une
association représentative puisqu'on a
été l'épreuve pionner dans une
organisation pluridisciplinaire celles
qui évoquent aujourd'hui le gouvernement
qui est de réunir en un même lieu un
certain nombre de professionnels qui
sont des chaînes de métiers qui peuvent
agir sur les violences depuis donné 14
on agit comme ça on a une convention
avec le barreau de versailles qui fait
des permanents chez nous depuis deux ans
trois ans maintenant on a conventionné
avec le parquet donc on a l'impression
d'être amer d'avoir été très avant
gardiste dans notre manière de prendre
en charge les femmes victimes de
violences les vols peut être intéressant
pour le lancement de ce grenelle
malheureusement les yvelines et on le
regrette souvent parce que quand on est
dans des réunions nationales on a
toujours l'impression que les yvelines
sont un département il ne s'y passe pas
grand chose
ou en tout cas où il fait bon y vivre
alors qu'en fait pour moi c'est un
département qui est la représentation de
ce qui se peut se passer dans les
provinces d'abord c'est un département
avec une grande zone rurale une grande
zone urbaine et puis des zones
prioritaires
donc on réunit finalement la
problématique d'une société réunis sur
un département ça pouvait être un bon
exemple de bonnes pratiques pour
apporter notre contribution
ce que nous avons fait en préalable du
lancement du grenelle mais porté par la
fondation des femmes qui ne nous a
peut-être pas suffisamment défendus pour
être finalement sur place au moment du
lancement
peu importe le lancement effet ce n'est
pas ça qui nous préoccupe et maintenant
c'est comment on va bénéficier
finalement 2-2 d'actions qui ont été
effectivement annoncé alors justement
parmi les grandes annonces annoncé hier
par le premier ministre edouard philippe
5 millions d'euros supplémentaires pour
créer 1000 nouvelles places
d'hébergement et de logement d'urgence
destinée aux victimes et généralisé
aussi la possibilité de porter plainte à
l'hôpital et ce à partir du 25 novembre
dans le volet juridique la création de
procureurs référence sur la question des
violences pour que les dossiers soient
traités sous quinze jours une
expérimentation sera d'ailleurs mené au
tribunal de créteil dans le val-de-marne
enfin la mise en place effective du
bracelet anti rapprochement donner la
possibilité au juge et de l'appliquer
après condamnation mais aussi avant et
c'est ça l'essentiel le mini la ministre
de la justice elle s'y est engagée pour
2020 votre réaction frédéric monde sait
ce que c'est des annonces qui vont dans
le bon sens est ce que c'est suffisant
vous avez liste et beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de choses qui coûtent qui coûte
quelque chose de bracelets électroniques
effectivement ça découpe d'abord on ne
l'a jamais utilisée alors qu'il avait
déjà été pensé il ya trois quatre ans
pourquoi parce qu'en face il faut un
système on va dire qui va permettre de
le mettre en place un système
associations parlent de d'un plan
marshall des violences conduire contre
les violences conjugales un milliard
d'euros sur ce questionnement on parle
de dessous et on les a jamais eu donc je
préfèrerais être raisonnable sur
l'aspect des budgets qui ont été
annoncées on va voir comment ils vont
redescendre vers des associations
terrain mais aujourd'hui trop
d'associations sont ignorés en fait dont
on va dire dans dans ce qu'elles savent
faire aujourd'hui et dans ce qu'elle
pourrait faire ensemble et le problème
des budgets c'est que les associations
elles se battent un peu un budget des
petits bouts de budget ce qui fait
qu'elles ne travaillent pas suffisamment
bien ensemble pour rester on va dire un
peu isolé et revendiquer une subvention
dans leur propre activité
après al avril il ya un préalable
pendant il faut les moyens ça fait il
faut des moyens parce que nous
aujourd'hui on est une association avec
des coûts fixes on embauche des
psychologues et des gens que l'on paye
aujourd'hui des professionnels pour agir
et on avait on a peu de soutien
financier aujourd'hui de l'état alors ce
grenelle
un peu à l'image du grand débat national
va se divise en plusieurs réunions
locales à ce sujet dans les yvelines est
la déléguée départementale aux droits
des femmes et à l'égalité nous indique
qu'une réunion dédiée aura lieu le 13
septembre prochain est ce que vous
alliez y être associés à cette région et
pour nous c'est un peu difficile parce
que nous sommes associés à des réunions
nationales et en revient au département
sachant que les femmes viennent de 51
départements vers les yvelines donc
c'est juste pour vous dire on peut
parler départementale
on va être sur un maillage territorial
assez précis mais si on prend le
comportement des victimes
on peut se retrouver dans une va dire
travailler bilatérales avec un autre
département sur lequel il faut
travailler donc il faut une méthodologie
beaucoup plus large que sur un
département même si analyser la
situation d'un département est
importante
vous n'avez pas la même réaction du
parquet de nanterre et du parquet de
versailles donc il faut comprendre ce
qui peut dysfonctionné pour l'améliorer
et ça c'est effectivement à travailler
plus tourné vers le lac un travail de
départements mais autrement
réfléchissons globalement les femmes ne
sont pas figés dans leurs départements
normands département justement vous êtes
plusieurs acteurs engagés dans la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
le cidff centre d'information pour le
droit des femmes et des familles qui a
cinquante antennes en tout sur le
territoire une aide psychologique est
apporté aussi juridique par le cidff
tout comme l'association en dire qu'il
ya des permanences dans les villes est
de montigny le bretonneux et trappes à
montigny le bretonneux d'ailleurs le
centre équinoxe héberge l'étincelle un
lieu d'accueil de jour des victimes et
enfin votre association frédéric martin
goodman safe qui prend en charge ces
femmes et aussi leurs enfants comment
d'ailleurs s'organise cette prise en
charge vous parliez tout à l'heure dans
un volet pluridisciplinaire c'est à dire
que plusieurs plusieurs choses voilà
c'est important de dire là vous avez
décrit des associations qui ont des
actions très précises conseil juridique
et puis prise en charge psychologique si
nécessaire nous y ajoutons le pan
l'élément sentez vous avez vous avez vu
que dans grenelle on parle très peu de
santé sauf à évoquer l'impact des
violences sur la victime et donc des
maladies qui s'installe et qui coûte
très très cher c'est je pense que les la
société ne se rend pas compte que un
état mauvais état de santé c'est un
mauvais état de santé que la société
subit par effectivement des arrêts
maladie des maladies chroniques qui
s'installe et c'est donc le volet santé
on a vraiment un plus dans notre format
pluridisciplinaire donc c'est vraiment
une prise en charge très globale
pourquoi les enfants parce que en
ouvrant sur les femmes
on s'est rendu compte que toutes ces
fameuses été soit victime enfant enfants
victimes et n'ont jamais été vu et
adultes elles reproduisent soit elle
continue à témoins ou soit-elle son
auteur elle même est notre premier atik
avaient été désarmées où sont des
enfants et comment on les traite
mais c'est vrai que les enfants cette
unité enfants que nous avons ouvert nous
l'avons voulue pour être vraiment dans
la prévention et la libération de ces
enfants qui assistent à des choses
absolument terrible on a bien évoqué
dans les violences conjugales combien de
deux femmes ont été tuées devant leurs
enfants alors c'est assez important et
c'est vrai que l'autre volet c'est les
violences sexuelles où nous agissons sur
les enfants de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance qui ont été victimes de graves
violences sexuelles dans leur enfance
évidemment dans l'intra familiale et
pour revenir juste à ce terme
violences conjugales moi je l'aurais
appelé intrafamiliales parce que
l'enfant il ne peut pas sortir d'un
débat qui veut protéger
l'adulte la mer sans pour autant être
protégé donc ce débat là il doit être
autour d'une cellule intrafamiliales on
parlait tout à l'heure de moyens votre
association a bien sûr besoin de moyens
pour fonctionner vous pouvez faire un
don à l'association ou même sexe dont le
site s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci beaucoup frédéric mar être passé
sur ce plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
la directrice et la co fondatrice de
cette association qui est basée à saint
germain en laye je le rappelle également
39,19 numéro d'écouté gratuit et anonyme
destiné aux femmes victimes de violences
j'ajoute enfin sur cette thématique un
portail de signalements gratuit et
anonyme des violences sexuelles et
sexistes et en place est depuis 2018 la
fin 2018 au commissariat de guyancourt
vous pouvez chatter avec un policier ou
un psychologue depuis votre ordinateur
smartphone ou tablette le portail est
ouvert 24 heures sur 24 est accessible
depuis le site des services ti
république à point fr elle lui a
justement voulu signaler donner la
parole à toutes les femmes victimes de
violence et qui n'osent pas parler le
jeune nantais benjamin moungalla alias
foudre d'éloquence a publié son premier
recueil de poèmes sur le sujet mathilde
de 2000 interrogé
la peur et l'angoissé sont les compagnes
de google le faire entendre raison
j'aurais tant voulu aimer cette fameuse
chanson et chacun tensions subies
l'espionnage
alors qu'ils silencieux c'est
un titre qui fait réfléchir déjà dans ce
sens où anouk simone saint-cricq
commente encore et ça met en avant des
personnes qui souffrent
travers des situations mais qui sont pas
mis en avant en l'occurrence là on parle
de femmes sont généralement qui est
souffre de violence conjugale de viol
d'agression
[Musique]
kim et moi même j'ai déjà puis une
expérience les avis de ceux là j'ai plus
ou moins de traverser cette situation et
puis pardonner et c'est aujourd'hui nous
sommes le premier je me dis que c'était
tout c'est un moyen pour partager les
autres
mon expérience et pouvoir aider d'autres
personnes
ya beaucoup de femmes que je connais
tous j'avais vu ce genre de choses la
dame une personnellement testé
confirmant c'est c'était une expérience
qui m'a vraiment touché dans le sens où
je connaissais pas forcément mais c'est
confiant moyens à m'a confié que voilà
aleph subi une tentative de viol et ça
explique beaucoup de choses
dans l'actualité locale cet appareil
testé depuis juillet qui mesurent le
niveau sonore des véhicules appelés
capteur mais du ce radar est installé
sur la route départementale 91 celle des
17 tournant reportage de manon varaldo
et gwenaëlle saintilan
après les radars classiques que vous
connaissez ou encore les radars
tourelles pour voir si vous êtes
attachés ou non place aux radars méduses
il est équipé d'une caméra et de quatre
micros qui permette de verbaliser les
véhicules trop bruyant ce radar méduse
peut aussi évaluer la direction de
provenance du bruit on a pris la
décision de mettre un petit capteur
photo dans le système dont le centre
optique est confondu avec le centre
acoustique du système ce qui permet en
gros 2 en prenant une photo de projeter
dans l'image le les directions nous
convier le bruit est donc d'avoir la
trajectoire réel ce radar méduse est
installé sur la route départementale 91
dans la vallée de chevreuse fameuse
route des dix sept tournant qui se veut
le terrain de jeu des motards une route
pourtant à limitée à 50 km heure il
suffit de venir se promener le samedi ou
le dimanche dans la vallée de chevreuse
pendant les mois d'été pour s'apercevoir
des nuisances considérable que subissent
les riverains et les habitants
l'installation de ce radar divise les
motards certains comprennent alors que
d'autres sont un peu sceptiques
ici on a la vallée de chevreuse il ya
des centaines de motards qui sont là
tous les jours et je peux comprendre que
pour les gens qui habitent juste en bas
de la vallée se doit pas être super
sympa d'entendre les rupteurs toujours
pas par exemple j'ai acheté deux moteurs
avec des pots qu'on était changé mon
normalement ils sont censés être
homologué mais c'est vrai qu'il fait
quand même assez de bruit et je me
demande si moi je peux passer à une
allure on va dire respectable sans prom
de pv le système de verbalisation est
encore l étude ce radar méduse est en
expérimentation pendant un an et demi
en ce mercredi quelques mots de cinéma
d'abord un record de fréquentation pour
les yvelines font leur cinéma tout l'été
le conseil départemental proposer des
projections de films en plein air dans
30 communes du département et dix mille
personnes ont participé en tout cette
année à l'opération parmi les longs
métrages les plus plébiscités on
retrouve d'abord un classique la grande
vadrouille avec bourvil et de funès le
film d'animation comme des bêtes et
aussi le sens de la fête co réalisé par
eric toledano libye nom est d'ailleurs
venu clôturer l'événement samedi dernier
à versailles et direction elancourt à
présent depuis près de 25 ans le ciné 7
est reconnu comme
salles art et essai un classement
renouvelé cet été et qui s'accompagne
d'un nouveau label après jeune public
patrimoine et répertoires le voici
labellisé recherches et découvertes
explications avec mélanie poker en
quand tu veux
j'achète pentecôte 1e conjectures
c'est en diffusant des films comme ce
long métrage polonais que le ciné 7 est
aujourd'hui labellisé recherches et
découvertes
une reconnaissance décernée par la fnaca
et l'association française des cinémas
art et essai sont les films peu diffusé
dans les salles cinéma européen cinéma
mondial qui sortent sur des petites
combinaisons de copies très souvent
version originale des films peu diffusé
donc en france voilà peu exposé que
public a du mal à trouver dans les
salles
donc ce cinéma là il faut le montrer
aussi il faut l'exposé il faut le mettre
en lumière et des films découvert lors
de festivals comme celui de cannes ou
par des coups de coeur de l'équipe du
cinéma et du public
ce label est décerné pour les deux
années à venir c'est le troisième que
reçoit le signer cette classé art et
essai depuis 1994
ça vient couronner un travail vraiment
d'equipe un travail de programmation
réalisée par les équipes ici sous la
houlette de luc beaucamp et puis c'est
un bonne nouvelle aussi bien entendu
pour les spectateurs qui viennent le
voir puisque c'est à la fois le gage
comme j'ai toujours dit d'un éclectisme
culturelle dans ce cinéma complet on a
une palette complète de toute
l'actualité cinématographique
on va bientôt du dollar essais mais ce
sont également les blockbusters il faut
pas les oublier parce qu'on a aussi une
clientèle qui vient pour les voir la
salle élan courtois se projette chaque
année entre 350 et 366 film le signer
cet accueil plus de 100000 cinéphiles le
début de saison on reprend les bonnes
habitudes du journal chaque mercredi
présentation de la programmation est
d'un cinéma de notre territoire ce soir
c'est le grenier à sel à trappes qui se
prête à l'exercice au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
retrouvez donc au cinéma le grenier à
sel à trappes
trois films qui sont nos coups de coeur
de cette semaine tout d'abord nous vous
proposons de ma famille et le loup qui
est un film franco espagnole à une
comédie familiale qui on pouvait voir
avec les enfants à partir de
2 6 7 8 ans au problème on suit le petit
hugo qui a 9 ans et qu'il a passé les
vacances c'est chez sa mamie avec ses
cousins toute sa famille qui l'a pas vu
depuis très longtemps et l'ama milan
raconter un peu l'histoire familiale et
leur raconte que le lou va venir la
chercher
donc allez un petit peu âgées on imagine
tout cela pour présenter le loup et
parle aussi du grand père
et toute leur histoire familiale et donc
les enfants tous les cousins vont se
souder ils vont être très solidaire pour
combattre le loup et protéger la famille
et la mamie c'est une très très belle
histoire familiale avec un mélange un
peu d'animation et de et de prises de
vues réelles
donc on vous conseille ma famille et le
loup nous avons aussi cette semaine
roubaix une lumière dernier film de
arnaud despléchin qui était en
compétition au festival de cannes
c'est un super polar avec roschdy zem
en policier à découvrir absolument
un autre coup de coeur de cette semaine
c'est 303 c'est une romance sous forme
de road movie
donc c'est un film allemand avec deux
jeunes qui traverse l'espagne
l'allemagne la belgique la france pour
aller jusqu'en espagne et qui refont le
monde c'est très beau c'est très tendre
et
et on a très envie de repartir en
vacances avec eux vous retrouvez donc
ces trois films ma famille le louroux b
et 303 au cinéma le grenier à sel je
vous dis à très vite
[Musique]
c'est l'événement de rencontres entre
les passionnés de mécaniques anciennes
motors and soul revient pour une sixième
édition c'est ce samedi et dimanche au
château de neuville à gambais plus de
25000 personnes sont venues elles lors
des précédentes éditions et pour en
parler stephan lhuillier bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le manager général de cet
événement déjà parlez-nous des origines
de motors and soul comment est né cet
événement ce rendez vous écoutez moi
dans un seul et n'est en fait d'une
communauté qui s'est fédérée autour d'un
blog s'appelle virage 8 est au bout d'un
certain temps on s'est dit tiens on va
se balader ensemble avec nos autos et
motos de caractère
cerci des véhicules anciens sont aussi
des vécus peut-être plus moderne avec
quelqu'un malgré leur âge ils conservent
tout leur caractère exactement et
surtout il ya une relation émotionnelle
avec ces véhicules soit il évoque
quelque chose soit et accessoirement une
nouvelle campagne entend donc ils nous
font vivre quelque chose mais surtout à
l'ail et une relation avec ces véhicules
et c'est si les membres de sa queue de
cette communauté sont dit il faut qu'on
se réunisse une fois par an et c'est
comme ça que nous avons un solide en
les objectifs c'est quoi c'est de faire
revivre chaque année cet état d'esprit
finalement exactement à laon où on fait
vivre tout au long de l'année la commune
est réunie sur des ballades d'une
journée sur des voyages etc
et puis elle se réunit complètement
parce que le bal à des voyages on a un
nombre limité et serait il est
complètement motors and soul c'est au
château de villa gombé sur un week-end
c'est le week-end prochain
on attend dix mille personnes
donc là effectivement beaucoup de
personnes une grosse organisation une
centaine de bénévoles de la communauté
qui se mobilisent simplement pour
partager notre passion pour partager
cette passion alors depuis le lancement
je le disais tout à l'heure plus de 25
mille participants sont venus sur cet
événement est ce qu'il prend davantage
de dimension chaque année alors lui a
grandi oui chaque année effectivement la
plus en plus de participants des
chiffres rapidement l'addition 9200 la
précédente 7000 la pressant dans le 4000
donc voilà en l'espace deux en l'espace
de trois ans on a carrément doublé le
nombre de participants la quantité
participants ce pas notre objectif
en fait notre objectif c'est de passer
deux jours très sympa de créer les
conditions pour que nos participants
viennent prendre plaisir
donc c'est de l'ordre des bonnes
vibrations fait donc on vient avec son
véhicule qu'il soit deux à quatre voire
à trois roues pour certains le véhicule
n'a pas besoin d'être un véhicule ancien
ou spécifiques on est ouvert à toutes
sortes de véhicules
la voiture ou la moto tous les jours
sont les bienvenus on va simplement les
laisser au parquet général
et puis pour les autres on va les
disposé devant le château de manière à
créer justement cette ambiance avec ce
cadre forcément agréable le château de
de granby château de neuville avril à
caen veille par donc le voilà dans cette
vallée de chevreuse et 1,5 cadre aussi
agréable alors la vallée de chevreuse
c'est juste un cadre magnifique donc
nous sommes à granby nous avons toutes
les routes environnantes et donc nous
proposons à 800 véhicules de les emmener
en balade
alors on appelle balade d'automobiles ou
ride moto c'est un petit peu notre
jargon
et puis nous avons deux types
d'itinéraires les routes scénique donc
les plus beaux paysages
c'est un anglicisme mais qu'importe nos
participants adore regarder les paysages
ou doucement et on regarde ce qui se
passe autour de nous et puis les routes
viroleuses donc là c'est le plaisir de
passer quelques bons virages ensemble
vous allez pas passer à côté du radar
senans dont on parlait tout à l'heure
absolument pas là nous sommes dans le
haut de la vallée de chevreuse donc dans
un triangle ou d'empoigné la forêt
montfort l'amaury donc des balades et
quels sont les autres animations
les autres animations six concerts donc
quatre concerts de samedi puisque samedi
soir nous avons une soirée jusqu'à
minuit à l'intérieur du château quand je
dis l'intérieur c'est dans la cour du
château de concert le dimanche des
expositions dont quatre constructeurs
qui veulent exposer et certains d'entre
eux vont faire ont proposé des essais
nous avons deux concours de style alors
on n'appelle pas ça concours d'élégance
chez nous on appelle ça des concours de
style puisque on demande aux
participants de venir habillés dans le
style vestimentaire de l'année de
production de leur véhicule donc ça
donne l'occasion à effectivement
différents styles sont donc les
véhicules soient des années 50 70 90 où
tout récent comment participer à
l'événement je crois qu'on peut
participer à une journée ou un week end
total ya deux tarifs en tout cas
absolument alors on peut on peut
participer le samedi ou dimanche tous
participé le week-end le tarif est à 15
euros pour une journée à 20 euros pour
le week end par personne et le tarif est
à 3 euros pour ce qui concerne la
participation ride et aux malades etc 3
euros sont reversés à une association
qui s'appelle une rose un espoir ce sont
des femmes qui ont été atteintes par le
cancer et qui nous aide dans
l'organisation en accompagnement les
balles les balades et des ryd et en
faisant le poste de secours
notre atout naturel que de les mettre
dans la mouvance et d'année dernière on
a eu le plaisir de leur remettre un
chèque de 1400 euros
on espère battre le chiffre mais en tout
cas voilà voilà
bon si c'est un objectif celui ci serait
serait très agréable ça fait partie de
vos attentes pour l'événement toutes les
informations et bien sûr à retrouver sur
le site internet de l'événement qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et je
rappelle donc c'est ce week end samedi
et dimanche au château de nos villes à à
granby merci stéphane mulliez je crois
que vous êtes le manager général de cet
événement absolument absolument merci
grégory et merci à tous les bénévoles
qui se mobilisent et à nos nombreux
visiteurs merci d'être passé sur ce
plateau et puis retour quelques jours en
arrière toujours en vallée de chevreuse
mai à saint rémy les chevreuse festival
août s'est déroulé pendant trois jours
le week-end dernier première édition de
cet événement pour mettre en avant le
patrimoine et le territoire du parc
naturel régional ambiance avec gwenaëlle
saintilan
des marionnettes géantes une fanfare la
parade d'ouverture du festival ont été
lancées ce jeudi 29 août et durant trois
jours ce nouveau festival dédié à la
valorisation de l'environnement de la
vallée de chevreuse des espaces naturels
et des artistes étaient mis en avant au
travers d'animations originales
au programme une visite de la ferme de
coubertin avec dégustation de fromages
pour les petits gourmands un moment pour
venir contempler les expositions
d'oeuvres d'art de profiter des nombreux
spectacles
[Musique]
ans
de venir participer à des ateliers
créatifs pour petits et grands et une
projection de films en plein air avec
pas moins de 400 spectateurs
[Musique]
pour ce dernier week end avant la
rentrée scolaire
la ville a misé sur une première édition
du festival mêlant patrimoine
environnement et spectacles un pari
réussi pour la mairie de la ville qui
n'hésitera pas à renouveler l'expérience
c'est la fin du journal retour de
l'information locale et en direct demain
dès 18 heures belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]